the Swedish singer Laureen has won the
Eurovision song contest for the second
time with her ballad tattoo the singer
beat acts from 25 other countries to
take the continent's pop Crown at the
competition in Liverpool Laureen
previously won Eurovision in 2012 and is
only the second performer to take the
prize twice Britain hosted Eurovision
this year on behalf of Ukraine which won
last year but could not take up its
right to hold the contest because of the
ongoing War there
you know right now Everything feels
surreal like I can't really you know I'm
seriously overwhelmed
so you have to ask me that question
tomorrow darling
this is so beautiful well you know 2012
everything was new for me like I was a
very naive girl I didn't know what to
expect you know and and so so
but this time you know it's like you've
heard this a million times but it's like
it's like coming back to a family like
hi guys we've had an 11 year long
relationship we know each other by now
so it's it's more this experience was
more
motherly and effortless like it was just
a nice flow man
I think
the key ingredients to any
success is being authentic
and to be authentic you need to
listen to yourself you need to know
yourself and for you to know yourself
you should take a step back
and um
don't ask people for advice
no I don't care about them
all I care about is you
Stuck on Me
[Applause]
[Laughter]
or party or party or party
[Applause]
[Laughter]
oh God